a tick tock influencer named Adriana
claims to have captured footage of a gym
employee quote being a pervert and
gawking at her while she takes her shirt
off and you may ask well what the hell
are you doing taking your shirt off in
the middle of the gym anyway here's the
video stand up for myself he threatens
to call the police and revoke my
membership
do you need something
okay I thought so
[Music]
yeah
no man at the gym been to many gyms in
my life men are not looking for any kind
of drama at all they're just there no
man wants to leave the gym with that
kind of story guess what happened at the
gym that's something that some women
look for and so we just need to be in
separate